see his numbers a year ago a 3.97 era
five and three lifetime against the
atlanta braves
and a call strike three
right at the knees if not a tad higher
and one out here in the first
lazuna coming off a solid year just
signed a four-year contract extension in
february ought to be a little
susceptible to ball away right now
second full count for efwin freddie
freeman will be off and running on the
pitch there he goes
and a cold strike three on the outside
corner second strikeout for effluent all
ian did was dazzle in the postseason
last year
yeah did a great job for the braves
making his first start of two thousand
twenty one reese hoskins two for nine
with a couple of rbis for the phillies
and hoskins drives this one a mile high
down the line and left ozuna in foul
ground will give way to dansby swanson
who tumbles to the foul line and makes
the catch there is wind and it is a high
sky nice play two out second and third
with two outs
it's the first inning and when you're a
two pitch pitcher you heard jeff talk
about it as well this is the trouble if
one of those pitches is off you either
have to find it quickly or have a third
pitch you can go to you have to keep
throwing it that's the thing so you live
by it you die by it you have to keep
throwing it until you figure it out
there you go birdie
man oh man
are right on time so was anderson with
his second strikeout
here's andrew knapp
maybe it's because
deep right field he hit it right off the
top of his head
a solo home run for andrew knapp first
one of the year for the bills it's one
nothing well ian anderson first time
yeah he's been at the plate i don't
think any of us know what to expect
a good swing there headed toward the gap
in left center it's going to get down a
base hit in his first major league
played appearance ian anderson's gonna
head first slide into second oh i love
that
so his first big league hit comes in
philadelphia on easter sunday
and the braves are in business with the
tying run aboard and acuna coming up
there's a line driving by
and they're going to catch anderson at
second base
i'm not sure if it was caught by segora
if it caught segora either way it's a
double play so you face bryce harper
with hoskins at first
and harper swung through that good
comeback for anderson he strikes out
harper for the first time today and
that's six strikeouts in the game yeah
he's all of a sudden found that grip on
that changeup and it's got it working
alec palm up it's all three balls two
strikes hoskins will take off there he
goes and a swing and a miss
anderson picks up his seventh strikeout
travis star no stepping in the bat now
philly's leading this one one nothing
here in the fourth
swing and a miss
one two three go to braves four
strikeouts for f this game's moving
right along aceh made his debut last
year against these philadelphia phillies
[Applause]
strike three right down the shoot at 92
miles an hour five strikeouts for zach
epwood
one nothing philly's leading it here in
the top of the sixth ender inciarte
who's pitch hitting for the pitcher ian
anderson is it
and a called strike three right on the
inside part of the plate it came back
six strikeouts for epwood
two away and aussie albies
swinging a looping drive towards center
gregorius reaching up and he's gone oh
wow
dede with a sensational play out in
shadow center field
that ball was by him and he reaches high
into the air
and he gloves it and comes down in a
tumble and hangs off
braves are first to the bullpen again
today this time it's tyler matsik
harper
baum and d.d gregorius do up got him in
august of 2019.
and he just whipped bryce harper looking
nobody on a 2-2 pitch
strike three call same pitch down at the
bottom of the zone
that got harper
boom walks away shaking his head
strike three how about that impressive
performance from matsik
three up three down three looking
strikeouts
one out for marcelo zuna
and a foul tip hung onto by knapp seven
strikeouts for f win two outs here in
the seventh inning
darnold for two as you see keeping
he hopes a four-game hit streak alive
and he just launched a hangar deep
toward left field a solo home run does
just that
and atlanta's first
home run by a regular comes from travis
darno
and we're tied one apiece in the seventh
inning well you had to feel at some
point they were going to break through
paul strike three a slider on the
outside corner eight strikeouts for
zach affleck
he allowed a home run to travis darneau
but threw seven one run
for eflin
and eight k's this afternoon
there's roman quinn he's going to pinch
hit for the pitcher effluent you're in a
1-1 game in the seventh minter looks it
first
and they've got it
andrew picked off
over the head of freddie freeman and
that goes to third
how about that
pitch on the way
swung on and miss got a fastball by him
and aj's fired up
mentor strikes out segura romuto and
quinn and he works around that throwing
here
reece is over three
line drive makes it to left field for
hoskins
third hit of the season for reese
bring harper to the plate one out one on
2-1
field that'll drop for a base hit
coskins around second puts the brakes on
a nice little lawn dart out to left
let's follow this up alec with another
one
one two is lined into center field of
basin hoskins around third heading for
home the throw to the plate is not in
time
alec foam comes through again
it all began last year as a rookie and
now carries over to his sophomore season
it's two-to-one phil
all right so the philly's trying to
finish off the sweep
so that puts two on
with two outs on back-to-back walks by
naris travis darneau is the battered
darno responsible for the one run of the
day for the braves on a home run
his last time up
two two pitch coming
into the air right center field harper
is there he's under it says he has it
and the ball game is over
the phillies have swept out the atlanta
braves to kick off the 2021 season they
win it today 2-1